setting up Clemson and LSU for a
national championship game that this man
is gonna call after he calls the Rose
Bowl between Oregon and Wisconsin later
on this week he's my buddy Chris Fowler
how are you Chris could be better rich
Happy Holidays Happy New Year I'll paint
the picture for you I'm looking at the
Roosevelt field as they paint it nice as
they're adding an extra shade of vivid
Oregon green to the endzone right now
but I guess I get to end and begin every
year in this beautiful place which
always fills me the gratitude so you
know what and obviously I feel a very
special affinity for the Rose Bowl being
a Michigan guy and I covered Bo
Schembechler last game in that building
against USC where junior say oh I
thought there was two of them on the
field that day there and but there is
nothing like the sunset during a Rose
Bowl over those San Gabriel Mountains on
the edge of that beautiful spot Chris
there's nothing like it man
nothing there's the physical setting
absolutely did everything that happens
on this field is bigger because it
happens at the Rose Bowl becomes a part
of the history of the sport but it's
beyond the beautiful grass and the
setting it it's the energy inside this
place but you feel along with about
90,000 people we lucky to be here that's
what everybody feels and when you put
that many people together feeling that
you know there's a kind of a collective
cool energy that I thought makes
everything that happens you're really
vivid like I have much stronger memories
of things that have happened in this
game compared to other games you see and
there's a power in the setting that
contributes to that and then of course
the national semifinal that was played
there a couple years ago between
Oklahoma and Georgia that you you you
know it was just dynamite and and I
gotta be honest with you obviously this
game did not go to overtime but Clemson
and Ohio State had a similar feel in the
fact that you knew that you'd see a lot
of these players on Sundays in the
future just the talent on that field
what and what was it like calling that
game for you Chris Fowler there would be
a mini series it was more of a mini
series in a game I mean there's so many
plot twists and turns and it had a
bloodbath
feel to it but he mentioned the NFL it
felt like one of those wars of attrition
you see where teams are battling in the
playoffs and whoever's got the most
healthy
bodies standing at the end might be the
winner guys were going out of the game
getting treated coming back in the game
a whole bunch of dudes on both sides
we're just digging really deep obviously
the plot to us included controversial
calls replays another thing you see in
your world of the NFL mm-hmm
so fans know how they feel aggrieved and
that's kind of too bad that their
takeaway was they got job by the
officials but I was just an absolute
classic you know it there were three
dominant teams in the sport all season
all three of them played like it and the
semi-final villus you did their thing as
you said these two teams as a shame one
side had to lose because but you got to
get to championship worthy teams that
battle for the end so you mentioned
those refereeing controversies of Chris
Fowler here on the Rich Eisen show Ryan
Day told your colleague Tom Rinaldi
after the game that he was angry what do
you think it was at the targeting call
or well it was the the fumble recovery
for a touchdown that got wiped out which
one you think they got all of them I
think all of either you feel like there
was a lot of crucial calls in the game
and not many of them if any of it went
his way
angry is putting it mildly I mean he was
behaving himself he was being
restraining to the press conference I
think he was absolutely livid and you
know when you're livid you point fingers
and you have conspiracy theories and all
that kind of stuff and I get that it
it's he feels for his team which was
good enough to win the game and may be
good enough to win a championship and
it's so hard to get there
you get their 13 and I for me the
targeting call was correct now you might
not like the rule habit I think the
players safety is pretty important in
the future of this sport at the pro
college and youth level depends on
better player safety so you got to have
punishment for targeting the other call
I think was incorrect I think they made
the right call in the field catch fumble
score now people are saying officials
were told telling us no no should never
have even been ruled complete on the
field to me cause the ball made a couple
steps and if I hear one more time made a
football made a movement common to the
game is what the hell is that does
anybody know what that is well isn't
isn't taking a step with the football in
your hand pretty common to the game you
know that is running common to the game
hey Chris
I'm with you I mean at the professional
football level heard about the Tuck rule
for so many years and the number of
times I would basically say when when
you are taking a football from a
throwing motion and pulling it into your
body doesn't that indicate you no longer
intend to throw it so why are we calling
it an incomplete pass I mean it's just
it's just the nature of our business in
the football world Chris you know no one
can tell me what it is
strike the pose and he he caught the
ball two three steps three and a half
the ball was knocked out of his hand
picked up and and is that indisputable
video evidence but that's not what
happened that's supposed to be the
standard and you get a lot of
double-talk
I'm with the fans I don't care who wins
the game I have no Bella preference
right which side wins I just call it
like I see it
I felt like that call there was no way
they're gonna overturn that on the field
and it was it was a scoop and score they
gave Ohio State believe will fight comes
in to win anyway of course in Ohio State
blame the officials exclusively of
course not
they made a million mistakes in that
game and I don't think officiating maybe
was the decisive factor but it was
certainly frustrated and that's the one
thing that I wish weren't a big
component to a game that great was that
lingering controversy Chris Fowler here
on the Rich Eisen show who's Trevor
Lawrence tell me about the kid
now that you've been around him for two
years very quiet very calm
amazing self-belief couldn't believe at
19 he did what he did last year to
Alabama in that game and it comes from
you know he's just a dude who's has a
deep faith doesn't believe that his
self-worth hangs in the balance every
time he throws a football so I think
from that comes a lot of confidence I
mean obviously if the the toughness
thing rich was what was on display the
other night he had one of his worst
games in terms of passing productivity
they just took the team on his back the
67-yard touchdown gallop is a play I'll
never forget the times he got it
including the targeting on waiver I
looked like he might be out for the
count I mean it looked like you know
like Tyson period hit him he
was laying on his back only missed a
play came back in and continued to run
the ball and take punishment that was a
big part of their game plan but if
you're gonna you're gonna make better
part in your game plan your quarter is
going to get hit a lot
and Ohio's it was violent they were
violent hitting the hitting and you know
except for waves hitting in a legal way
mm-hmm and he stood in there and did it
night I can't wait to see him versus
Berlin the championship is you get to
four different styles of quarterback but
guys who are playing at the top level
who haven't lost and you know it's like
who do you trust more
who's gonna execute more in the
championship moment for me it's just
hard to bet against Trevor Lawrence
based on what he's done so far well I
mean in a career you've segment Chris
Fowler to the next subject I mean that
that gallop that you referred to the by
Lawrence I tweeted at the time and it
might cause half the NFL to tank 2024
the 2021 Draft and and and and the
national championship may just be the
quarterbacks who are going to be chosen
first overall in the next two NFL drafts
and and in terms of burrow Chris have
you can you compare him to anybody else
that you've witnessed callgames or
covered in any way shape or form from
back in the day with with college
gameday who went from you know
serviceable or that which is obviously
negatively connoted or or or good to
all-time haven't seen this type of
before type of performance in one year
Chris is there any comparison from what
we've seen out of burrow no I I don't I
don't think to go from I mean he really
sort of came alive at the end of last
year but no one expected this kind of a
season I think the mental component was
already always there he's always a
really bright dude that's what struck
LSU in the first interview they had with
him when he was going to transfer them
Ohio says this guy might be the smartest
football mine in the room it was
including yellow shoe coaches and I
think they were blown away by that part
of it he prepares like a pro already he
takes one class I think he's already
graduated so he he spends all this time
in a football complex kind of walking
around and when he comes into his
meetings at the beginning of the week
he's got game plan ideas already from
watching tape on his own that's just not
college soft right that's NFL veteran
stuff in
a lot of guys if it and legal editors
can't do that so it begins with that and
then you know Joe Brady that you know
Saints fans will know what he did at
that level I think it's a perfect
marriage a play caller skiing
quarterback and let's not forget he's
surrounded by a bunch of playmakers and
an offensive line that basically blocks
with a five man protection a lot and
they can do that because you get the
ball out so fast his release is quick
I'll give you a scouting report that is
interesting i watch some field level but
the first time in atlanta against
georgia and i was just you know on the
fan watching the game and it's a unique
perspective because you can see things
differently than you can from the press
box and certainly a lot different and
watch it on TV but what struck me is how
athletic he is he's almost balletic in
the pocket and in escaping his sudden he
can he can crease defenses faster than
you think straight ahead speed throwing
it of all he's not the most beautiful
passer and he actually thought he threw
the ball poorly he did he's a pretty
high grader of himself he didn't spin
like to uh it doesn't come out of his
hand tight like a lot of guys who throw
it on Sunday you throw a wobbly pass now
and then it's incredibly accurate his
his sense of timing his decision-making
is stellar and he's capable of throwing
a lot of beautiful passes it just
doesn't come out of his hand
flawlessly every time like we see with
some of these guys but but that doesn't
matter cuz he's so good in so many areas
Chris Fowler here on the Rich Eisen show
in a couple minutes I have left with you
Chris I'm gonna take a moment for myself
and and and ask you some advice and my
friendship with you based on a based on
a colleague of ours Mike Tirico so you
know Mike high-class individual like
a-plus
okay he texted me and a group of other
of our colleagues during my show Sunday
game day morning yesterday he texted me
and Curt Menefee James Brown Sam ponder
and Carissa Thompson to tell all of us
who hosts NFL pregame shows great job
love watching you all here you know
we'll see you down the road of the Super
Bowl have a great final week of shows
like typical Mike Tirico a plus Wow
awesome high class material and you've
known Mike for longer than I
so current Menifee responds and says hey
you know great stuff and right right
back at you James Brown did you know his
usual a plus first class response as
well
Sam ponder said hey thank you appreciate
it see all in Florida soon I came up
with a response here Chris and I asked
Kurt Warner who's one of the nicest
people I know should I send it he said
yes here's what I sent in response I
wrote back sorry since I'm the only one
here hosting a four-hour show I'm just
seeing this today there's warmth and
generosity you see pettiness everybody
on this chain you know see at the Super
Bowl great season and then nobody
responded Chris do you think do you
think I've got an issue here what do you
think I think you made enemies
I think you've instantly made enemies
and you might be scorned and you'll
never be in another group texts again
I mean Curtis like seriously the nicest
person on the planet he's like sending
he found it funny you know I find it
funny - I mean how many people can say
happy new jersey chose to go the other
direction
if you didn't have the first bite of the
Apple in all seriousness manic as he
called it he did that and no doubt
there's hopefully a little bit more of
that in the business I think that Mike
and I sent text and Joe tests and sean
mcdonagh and in Joe Davis it box it's
really nice to have your peers say hey
you did a good job it means a hundred
times more than a fan what a fan says
positive or negative and when your peers
recognize that and aren't afraid to
express it I think it's thanks for
telling me that that made my day to hear
that make the debt you know want to
fight your sophomoric responses I was
looking for moral support here and it
just makes me feel worse Chris I'll be
honest with you you know
thanks for the call Chris by the way
great and they say I mean and I just
love listening to you man you and
Herbstreit were on it I thought herb
streets instant analysis of the final
interception and what happened was so
spot-on and made something totally
confusing crystal clear as to why it
happened and the pictures that followed
it up I mean that's just one small part
of how fantastic that Fiesta Bowl
broadcast was Chris really just in this
spot see Rachel asking to leave you it
he played at Ohio State captain so is
his dad he feels deeply about the school
there's a great job being objective his
twin sons are playing for Clemson I said
you're never in your life's going to
have a night like this one family forget
forget doing a broadcast and trying to
do your usual unbiased job his kids are
in uniform now not plan but they're
gonna get a championship ring there
Clemson wins they already got two rings
from the season and their first year
playing Ohio State a spot in the
championship game imagine being him I
mean it was he was vibrating it a little
higher frequency it was great I look
forward to seeing you on the Rose Bowl
broadcast and then obviously the
national champion the Australian Open
and beyond say hello to Jennifer for me
will you please yes I hopefully will
talk before them but I appreciate that
afternoon I got you a Chris Fowler right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app